salut les épicurus et les épicurieux
aujourd'hui on va parler de trois
monstres légendaires celui du Loch Ness
qui joue à cache-cache depuis près d'un
siècle en Écosse le Yéti un abominable
homme des neiges qui se planque dans
l'Himalaya et le redoutable Kraken qui
sème la terreur dans les océans ces
trois créatures extraordinaires
sont-elles sorties de l'imagination des
hommes ou bien y a-t-il un fonds de
vérité dans ces histoires aujourd'hui on
démêle le vrai du faux ça va être
monstrueux
[Musique]
il faudra mettre de l'huile bienvenue
dans mon atelier si ce format vous plaît
n'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo et à vous
abonner on pourra continuer à se faire
peur avec ses créatures redoutables nous
partons d'abord pour l'Écosse au sud de
la région des Highlands c'est ici que se
cacherait le célèbre monstre du Loch
Ness Messi pour les intimes il a été
photographié en 1934 cette année là deux
amis se promènent tranquillement sur les
rives du lac écossais quand tout à coup
le regard est attiré par une étrange
créature qui nage en surface ils sont
scotchés l'animal possède un long cou il
ressemble à si méprendre à un dinosaure
par chance l'un des deux hommes est
équipé
d'un appareil photo Robert Wilson c'est
son nom son prénom
d'appuyer sur le déclencheur sa photo
vous l'avez forcément déjà vu dans les
livres elle est aussi au publiée dans le
Daily Mail un journal britannique très
populaire et le cliché fait aussitôt le
tour de la planète chose inattendue du
jour au lendemain le monde entier se
presse sur les rives du Loch Ness avec
l'espoir d'apercevoir la créature autant
vous dire que pour les hôteliers du coin
c'est une aubaine plus que là les
touristes ne se bousculaient pas sur les
bords du Loch Ness pourtant ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'une bête à l'allure
préhistorique et signalée dans le lac en
1933 un couple avait déjà prétendu avoir
aperçu un énorme animal rouler à la
surface et plongé 1933 un an avant la
photo les premières traces de cette
créature remonteraient même allant 565
un missionnaire irlandais visitant la
région témoignent avoir surpris un
monstre rugissant en train d'attaquer un
homme il leur est ensuite sauvé en
faisant fuir la couverture avec un signe
de croix alors
myth ou réalité à l'époque les
scientifiques intrigués se penchent sur
la question car il pourrait s'agir d'un
plaisir un animal aquatique qui a vécu
au Crétacé aurait-il miraculeusement
survécu à l'extinction des dinosaures il
y a 65 millions d'années cette hypothèse
et séduisante mais elle est loin de
faire l'unanimité à cause du coût de
Messi d'après la photo celui-ci est
courbé or le plésiosaure possédait un
coup droit et rigide de plus c'était un
animal marin qui n'aurait pas survécu
dans les eaux douces du Loch Ness ces
arguments scientifiques sont imparables
et pourtant il ne parviennent pas à
convaincre ceux qui croient à
l'existence de la créature pour eux mais
si n'est peut-être pas un plésiosaure il
pourrait parfaitement appartenir à une
autre espèce préhistorique de nombreuses
expéditions sont alors organisées sur le
lac dans le but de dénicher des indices
durant plusieurs décennies le Loch Ness
est fouillé sont des centimètres carrés
par centimètre carré mais en vain pas la
moindre trace de Messi et si toute cette
histoire n'était qu'un canular la photo
à montage la réponse à cette question
sera obtenue en 1993 cette année-là
Christian pearling le compère du
photographe révèle enfin que le monstre
de la photo était un lieu hier morceau
de carton découpé fixé sur un sous-marin
d'enfant c'était une grosse blague et
tout le monde a plongé fin de l'histoire
et bien détrompez-vous le célèbre lac
écossais attire toujours autant les
touristes et les scientifiques en juin
2018 une équipe néo-zélandaise n'a pas
hésité à mener une étude sur 250
échantillons collectés dans les eaux du
Loch Ness et centaines de millions de
séquences ADN ont été analysées et
comparé avec de nombreuses bases de
données les résultats ont conduit les
scientifiques à écarter définit
l'hypothèse d'un reptile venue du fin
fond du Crétacé en revanche le lac
regorgerait bien de poissons à long cou
mais il s'agit de simples anguilles qui
tombe maintenant les brumes de l’écosse
pour nous rendre sur les pentes de
l'Himalaya c'est ici à la frontière du
Tibet de l'Inde et du Népal que se
cacherait l'abominable homme des neiges
un être effrayant de plus de 2 mètres de
hauteur couvert de longs poils et
affublé d'une énorme tête la possibilité
de son existence est révélée en 1951 par
Eric Shipton un explorateur britannique
qui tente de gravir l'Everest durant le
trajet il fait une étrange découverte il
s'agit du empreinte de piégeante
interloquée par sa taille et par sa
forme il la prend en photo et poursuit
sa route une fois rentrée en Angleterre
l'explorateur propose son cliché à
différents magazines qui le publient
aussitôt la photo fait sensation cette
empreinte de pied ne ressemble à rien de
connu et les scientifiques qui se
penchent dessus se posent des questions
ressemble à celle d'un hominoïde la
famille qui comprend les êtres humains
et les grands singes mais elle est bien
trop grande pour être celle d'un homme
et aucun des grands singes connus ne
pourrait survivre dans cette région du
monde
s'agirait-il alors d'une supercherie
impossible
Eric Clipton est un explorateur qui
jouit d'une excellente réputation jamais
il n'aurait osé faire une chose pareille
certains avancent alors que ce pied
pourrait appartenir à une créature my
homme mi singe très présente dans les
légendes locales du Tibet et du Népal le
Yéti Yéti dans la langue locale signifie
homme sauvage en France on y trouve un
autre nom l'abominable homme des neiges
à partir des années 50 le monde
occidental se passionne pour cette
créature que l'on décrit comme un
dangereux mangeur d'homme Hergé le
célèbre créateur de Tintin profite de
cet engouement pour en faire un
personnage de premier plan dans les
aventures de Tintin au Tibet le Yéti
prend la forme d'une bête effrayante
mais dotée d'un cœur d'or en attendant
les années passent et les scientifiques
sont dans l'incapacité de mettre un nom
sur la créature qui a laissé cette
empreinte dans la neige si bien qu'en
2012 Bryan sights un généticien
britannique qui n'a pas froid aux yeux
lance une vaste étude consacrée à
l'abominable homme des neiges il ne
s'intéresse pas à la photo mais à des
poils d'animaux non identifiés récoltés
sur les pentes de l'Himalaya le
scientifique collecte 57 échantillons et
compare leur ADN à celui d'un ancêtre de
l'ours polaire qui a vécu en Norvège il
y a entre 120 000 et 40.000 ans ces
conclusions sont formelles 55
échantillons appartiennent à des animaux
bien connus cheval vache lourd à ton
laveur et même porc-épic mais les deux
derniers ont une correspondance avec cet
ours disparue surprise le Yéti pourrait
être un croisement entre un ours brun et
un ours polaire disparu il y a des
milliers d'années un mystère chasse
l'autre
si vous avez tremblé devant Pirates des
Caraïbes au cinéma vous allez trembler
devant notre dernière créature
légendaire
Kraken le capitaine du bateau fantôme le
Hollandais volant se sert de ce calamar
géant au multiple tentacules pour
anéantir les navires ennemis Jack
Sparrow alias Johnny Depp mais un
terrible combat contre lui dans le
deuxième volet de la saga le Kraken fait
couler les navires mais il fait aussi
couler beaucoup d'encre depuis le
Moyen-âge la description quand donne les
auteurs scandinave de l'époque de ne pas
envie de le rencontrer je les cite c'est
un monstre qui sème la terreur dans les
mers qui séparent la Norvège et
l'Islande il est capable d'avaler des
hommes des bateaux et des baleines le
Kraken mesure des dizaines de mètres
d'envergure et pourrait atteindre la
taille d'une petite île la créature doit
son eau au monorvégien craqueux qui
signifie animal malsain tout un
programme du coup ce redoutable calamar
est-il sorti de l'imagination des marins
ou bien y a-t-il un fond de vérité dans
cette histoire de nombreux témoignages
récoltés par le passé
semble confirmer son existence le plus
célèbre remonte à 1861 une émane d'un
marin français le capitaine de frégate
Frédéric Bouillet celui-ci affirme que
nord-est de Tenerife en pleine océan
Atlantique son navire s'est trouvé nez à
nez avec le fameux Kraken selon ses
dires la rencontre a été houleuse ces
hommes se sont vu contraints de sortir
les harpons et les fusils pour ne pas
finir entre cette tentacule Frédéric
Bouillet relate cette rencontre dans un
rapport qu'il soumet à la très sérieuse
académie des sciences il a également
conservé un morceau du Kraken qu'il a
fait parvenir à un biologiste mais
celui-ci est incapable de déterminer la
nature exacte de cet animal l'affaire
fait beaucoup de bruit si bien que des
années plus tard je le Verne s'en
inspire pour son roman d'aventure Vingt
mille lieues sous les mers il contribue
ainsi à populariser le mythe du Kraken
dans le monde entier la plupart des
scientifiques en sont sûrs cette
créature existe bel et bien il s'agit
femme calamar géant sa taille a sans
doute été exagéré par les navigateurs et
les pêcheurs mais il pourrait quand même
atteindre 13 mètres d'envergure on sait
peu de choses sur lui car il vit dans
les grandes profondeurs il est donc
particulièrement difficile de l'observer
et d'analyser son comportement mais en
2012 une équipe scientifique japonaise a
pu filmer pour la première fois un
calamar géant par 900 mètres de fond
dans l'océan Pacifique la longueur de
l'animal est estimée à 8 mètres depuis
personne n'a jamais recroisé le terrible
Kraken vivant le dernier spécimen connu
a été retrouvé en 2022 sur une plage de
nouvelles Zélande mais il était mort et
partiellement dévoré je suis curieux de
savoir lequel de ces trois monstres vous
avez préféré ou lequel vous a fait le
plusteur j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu alors n'hésitez pas à liker et à
vous abonner et puis si vous aimez ce
genre d'histoire signalez le moi
également en commentaire j'en ai plein
les tiroirs à très bientôt
chers épicurieuses et épicurieux
[Applaudissements]